everything
if it's not made from steel it's made
with steel
it is the most important of All Metals
but how do we actually make it well in
the following video I'll show you what
it takes
[Music]
begins here on the Dockside in Wales
where iron ore and coal arrive from
Brazil Sweden and all over the world
those rocks get offloaded onto the dock
side and here you've got the Main
Ingredients coal which gets baked into
what's known as Coke iron ore with about
60 Iron as well as magnesium and a few
other things
they get emptied into the top of one of
these two blast furnaces here a few
hundred yards from the docks those
furnaces are constantly running the
temperature inside them getting to over
2 000 degrees C at its hottest point now
we are basically at the very
epicenter of this glass furnace here in
Port Talbot and the reason this is the
epicenter is that this behind here is
pretty much the hottest point these are
known as twiers they are pumping hot air
into the very core of this glass furnace
at the very top you've got your iron ore
going in you've got your Coke as well
the type of coal and a flux as well and
that all goes in there into a big pile
and then essentially as it goes down it
kind of melts and melts but this is the
hottest point so it's only the starting
point really of a process that takes
that iron through and turns it into
steel and then after that you get it
turned into Steel sucks which are the
kind of things that we recognize
but in a sense it begins here and it's
quite an extraordinary Place loud noisy
a little bit smelly as well and most of
all very very hot
then every so often they drill a hole in
a clay section near the bottom of the
furnace and look what happens next these
are molten iron Sparks as the liquid
metal begins to gush out this is pig
iron iron with about five percent carbon
or so
it passes along channels like this in
the floor it's well over a thousand
degrees at this point actually hotter
than lava and it gets poured into a kind
of train Carriage vessel called a
torpedo the torpedo takes the pig iron
to another big Hangar where it gets
emptied into a vessel where some of the
impurities are removed and the iron goes
into something called a basic oxygen
converter which fires supersonic oxygen
through a nozzle and that removes most
of the remaining carbon the finished
product is yes
steel and this is where you add lots of
exotic things to give it special
properties Boron or Vanadium for high
strength Steels silicon for electrical
Steels has hundreds of different recipes
now this extraordinary Contraption here
is where liquid seal is poured and then
it is essentially cool so you've got
water cold water sprayed on it all the
way down here through that Loop going
down here that's why there's so much
steam there and grantally the liquid
steel becomes solid so it's cast into
these thick slabs red hot slams still
glowing with heat why is it glowing us
because it's about 1100 degrees C if I
put my hand anywhere near it's it's
essentially going to be burnt
this is only in a sense the middle of
the long process between iron and
finished steel products
that glowing steel get
still get such inflamed into 30-foot
slabs which get lifted onto the next
stop here they're heated up again and
slid onto the biggest machine you've
ever seen where the thick slab is run
again and again through these enormous
rolling presses until they end up barely
a few millimeters thick what began as a
30-foot slab can come out more than a
kilometer long the coils are pressed
again and galvanized and then they get
transported to another plant then
they're fed into enormous presses where
they're sliced into shapes this robot
then takes two different grades of Steel
and Laser welds them together and here's
the finished product
look the right hand bit of this door is
ultra high strength steel the bit on the
left is lower strength it may not look
very high tech but it's thanks to
techniques like this that cars are
lighter and safer than ever before
by the time you've watched this this
steel will be in a finished car and
there are other ways of making steel
from scrap or even green steel but for
the time being this is still the Journey
of Steel in the UK from Iron heavy Rock
On The Dockside in South Wales to a
Precision product we all use